>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IN 1980,
WHICH WASN'T THAT LONG AGO,
VENEZUELA WAS THE RICHEST
COUNTRY IN LATIN AMERICA, IT HAD
THE HIGHEST WAGES, THE BEST
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION.
IT ALSO HAD BY THE STANDARDS OF
THE REGION ANYWAY FAMOUSLY
STABLE DEMOCRACY.
THEN CAME AN ENERGY CRISIS AND
VENEZUELA WOUND UP WITH
INFLATION.
AT TIMES IT REACHED 100% A YEAR.
INFLATION MAKES PEOPLE POORER,
SO IN A VERY SHORT TIME THE
POVERTY RATE IN VENEZUELA
DOUBLED.
BY 1995, 66% OF ALL VENEZUELANS
WERE IMPOVERISHED.
GETTING POORER TENDS TO MAKE
MOTORS RADICAL SO INEVITABLY
VENEZUELA GOT RADICAL POLITICS.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED NEXT,
VENEZUELA IS NOW RATED ONE OF
THE MOST MISERABLE PLACES ON
PLANET EARTH.
A FEW YEARS AGO, CITIZENS IN
CARACAS WERE REDUCED TO EATING
ZOO ANIMALS.
THERE WAS NO FOOD, FOR THAT
MATTER THERE WAS NO ELECTRICITY.
SEVEN JUST HALF A LIFETIME, AN
ADVANCED SOCIETY HAD RETURNED TO
THE STONE AGE.
UNITED STATES IS NOT IN DANGER
OF BECOMING VENEZUELA NEXT WEEK
BUT WE ARE MOVING CLOSER TO IT.
INFLATION IS A BIG PART OF THE
REASON.
OF ALL THE ECONOMIC CRISES A
COUNTRY CAN FACE, INFLATION IS
THE MOST DANGEROUS.
INFLATION DOESN'T JUST MAKE
PEOPLE POORER, IT TOTALLY
DESTROYS THEIR CONFIDENCE IN
THEIR LEADERS, THE AUTHORITIES
WHO ISSUE THE NOW WORTHLESS
CURRENCY THEY ARE USING FOR
TOILET PAPER.
INFLATION IS NOT AN ACT OF GOD
LIKE A DRUG OR HURRICANE, IT IS
AN ACTIVE GUY WOULDN'T LIKE
DRUNK DRIVING.
IT IS PROOF THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
ARE RECKLESS AND STUPID.
THAT IS WHY INFLATION TENDS TO
TOPPLE GOVERNMENTS.
ONCE YOU GET INFLATION THERE IS
NO PRETENDING YOU HAVE DONE A
GOOD JOB, YOU HAVE NOT DONE A
GOOD JOB AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS VERY WORRIED
ABOUT THIS.
JOE BIDEN HAS HISTORICALLY LOW
APPROVAL RATINGS.
IT VOTERS THAT INFLATION IS
THEIR TOP CONCERN.
THE HISTORICAL FACTS ARE
DIRECTLY RELATED.
BIDEN'S MOST PRESSING TASK RIGHG
AMERICANS THAT HE UNDERSTANDS
THEY ARE SUFFERING UNDER
INFLATION AND UNDER A RAPIDLY
WORSENING ECONOMY AND THAT HE
HAS A PLAN TO FIX IT.
IF HE CAN'T CONVINCE AMERICANS
OF THAT IT MAY BE A LONG TIME
BEFORE WE HAVE ANOTHER
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
THANKFULLY, JOE BIDEN HAS A PLAN
OR AT LEAST A NEW PUBLICIST, THE
SILVER TONGUED WORDSMITH/POLICY
GURU CALLED KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
IT IS KARINE JEAN-PIERRE'S JOB
TO TAKE THIS MESSAGE OF ECONOMIC
HOPE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
SAVE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
SHE STARTED MONDAY.
HERE WERE HER FIRST WORDS FROM
THE PODIUM.
>> I AM OBVIOUSLY ACUTELY AWARE
THAT MY PRESENCE AT THIS PODIUM
REPRESENTS A FEW FIRSTS.
I AM A BLACK GAY IMMIGRANT
WOMAN, THE FIRST OF ALL THREE OF
THOSE TO HOLD THIS POSITION.
>> Tucker: SO, THAT WAS A
LITTLE CONFUSING, IT WAS NOT
ABOUT AMERICA, IT WAS ABOUT HER,
BUT STILL WE LEARNED THAT
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE IS A BLACK
LESBIAN, THE FIRST EVER IN
HISTORY SHE REMINDED US TO HOLD
THIS PARTICULAR JOB, LISTEN
CAREFULLY.
THAT SHATTERING YOU HEAR IN THE
BACKGROUND, IT IS 1,000 GLASS
CEILINGS CRACKING SIMULTANEOUSLY
INTO MILLIONS OF TINY PIECES AND
THEN BEING SWEPT WITH THE
CUSTODIANS OF TOMORROW INTO THE
TRASH BIN OF BIGOTRY AND HATE.
SOON THEY WILL BE TRUCKED TO A
LANDFILL AND BURIED.
IT IS A NEW DAY, AMERICA.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
YOU STILL CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
YOUR REFRIGERATOR FIXED OR GO TO
THE DENTIST.
ON THE OTHER HAND,
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE HAS GOOD NEWS
FOR YOU ABOUT HERSELF.
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE HAS JUST
REACHED A HIGHLY SIGNIFICANT
PERSONAL GOAL, AND
UNDERSTANDABLY, SHE IS BRIMMING
WITH SELF-ESTEEM.
CONGRATULATIONS,
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
YOUR PROMOTION IS AMERICA'S
PROMOTION.
HOPE IT FEELS GOOD.
YOU ARE GOING TO WANT TO HOLD
ONTO THAT SENSATION, THE ONE YOU
ARE NOT EXPERIENCING, AND
TREASURE IT IN THE DAYS AHEAD
LIKE A HAND WARMER.
AS AMERICA BECOMES POORER THAN
YOU EVER IMAGINED POSSIBLE, AND
IT IS.
AS OF TONIGHT, PARENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CAN'T FIND BABY
FORMULA.
OH, NO BIG DEAL.
WELL IT IS ACTUALLY A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE AS A RESULT OF THAT,
SEVERAL CHILDREN HAVE JUST BEEN
HOSPITALIZED IN THE STATE OF
TENNESSEE.
FERTILIZER PRICES MEANWHILE HAVE
HIT RECORD HIGHS.
THAT WILL MEAN FOOD SHORTAGES
AROUND THE WORLD.
FAMINE IN SOME PLACES,
STARVATION.
IT WILL MEAN SHORTAGES HERE.
FOOD INFLATION, BLOOMBERG
REPORTS WILL "LEAVE NO HOUSEHOLD
UNSCATHED."
AND THEN GAS PRICES ALSO JUST
HIT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
THEY ARE NOT GOING DOWN.
MIKE JENNINGS, CEO AT A MAJOR
REFINER, SAYS GAS PRICES WILL
STAY HIGH FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
"I DON'T SEE ANY SIGNS OF IT
ENDING SOON OR WELL."
AND THAT IS TRUE OF INFLATION
ACROSS EVERY MAJOR SECTOR OF
THIS ECONOMY.
AXIOS REPORTING TONIGHT THAT
"INFLATION IS PUSHING PRICES
HIGHER AND HIGHER AND SOME OF
THOSE COSTS MAY NEVER COME BACK
DOWN TO THE LEVELS AMERICANS
WERE ACCUSTOMED TO BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC."
MORE THAN HALF THE CEOs IN
THIS COUNTRY PUBLICLY PREDICT
THAT RECESSION IS IMMINENT.
THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IN
PUBLIC, IMAGINE WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING IN PRIVATE.
MORGAN STANLEY SAYS THERE IS A
27% CHANCE WE GET A RECESSION IN
THE NEXT 12 MONTHS.
THAT IS UP FROM 5% JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
SO THAT IS SCARY, BUT THE
SCARIEST FACT OF ALL, WE APPEAR
TO BE RUNNING OUT OF ENERGY.
CONGRESS NEVER PASSED THE GREEN
NEW DEAL BUT WE SOMEHOW GOT IT
ANYWAY.
AND HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," "FROM
CALIFORNIA TO TEXAS TO INDIANA,
ELECTRIC GRID OPERATORS ARE
WARNING THAT POWER GENERATING
CAPACITY IS STRUGGLING TO KEEP
UP WITH DEMAND.
THAT GAP COULD LEAD TO ROLLING
BLACKOUTS DURING HEAT WAVES OR
OTHER PEAK PERIODS AS SOON AS
THIS YEAR."
IN OTHER WORDS, TURN ON YOUR
AIR-CONDITIONING IN AUGUST AND
IT WILL NOT WORK AND NEITHER
WILL YOUR LIGHTS.
THE MIDCONTINENT INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR WHICH OVERSEES
THE ENERGY GRID IN THE MIDWEST
SAYS IT IS PREPARING TO "TAKE
EMERGENCY MEASURES IN ADVANCE OF
CAPACITY ISSUES THIS SUMMER."
IN OTHER WORDS, NO MORE
ELECTRICITY.
THE NORTH AMERICAN ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY CORPORATION WHICH
OVERSEES ENERGY OUTPUT IN THE
COUNTRY RELEASED AN ASSESSMENT
THIS YEAR SAYING THE ENTIRE
WESTERN U.S. IS "AT RISK OF
ENERGY EMERGENCIES DUE TO THE
LIMITED SUPPLY OF ELECTRICITY
AVAILABLE FOR TRANSFER."
SO THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED.
IT IS HAPPENING NOW.
WHY?
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," "THE
CHALLENGE IS THAT WIND AND SOLAR
FARMS WHICH ARE AMONG THE
CHEAPEST FORMS OF POWER
GENERATION DON'T PRODUCE
ELECTRICITY AT ALL TIMES AND
NEED LARGE BATTERIES TO STORE
THE OUTPUT FOR LATER USE THE
SPORT.
NOW, THAT'S NOT ONLY A BIG
PROBLEM, IT TURNS OUT TO BE AN
INSURMOUNTABLE PROBLEM.
GIVEN THAT NEARLY HALF OF NEW
ELECTRICITY GENERATION CAPACITY
IN THE U.S. LAST YEAR, 42%, WAS
FROM LAND-BASED WIND FARMS.
PUT A LOT OF EGGS IN THE WIND
BASKET, SOME STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA HAVE PLEDGED TO USE
100% "RENEWABLE ENERGY BY 2045."
SO MAYBE WE WILL HAVE SCIENTIFIC
INNOVATION BY 2045 TO MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE, IF WE DON'T,
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE LESS POWER
THAN IT DOES NOW.
YOU DIDN'T THINK GROWING UP IN
THIS COUNTRY THERE WOULD COME A
TIME WHEN THEY COULDN'T KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON NOW THAT TIME IS HERE.
IT IS SHOCKING.
BUT IF YOU ARE UPSET ABOUT IT,
WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO PAUSE AND
RETURN YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
FACT, AND WE ARE GOING TO SAY
THIS SLOWLY SO IT CAN SINK IN,
OUR NEW WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY IS A BLACK
LESBIAN.
HA, HOORAY!
THE PRESS CORPS WAS DULY
IMPRESSED.
BUT OUR PETER DOOCY DID HAVE ONE
QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOING ABOUT OUR COLLAPSING
ECONOMY AND HOW EXACTLY IS THE
PLAN TO INCREASE TAXES ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS GOING TO HELP
THEM PAY FOR THINGS?
HERE IS HOW KARINE JEAN-PIERRE
RESPONDED.
>> HOW DOES RAISING TAXES ON
CORPORATIONS REDUCE INFLATION?
>> SO, ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT A
SPECIFIC TWEET?
>> TWEETED, YOU WANT TO BRING
DOWN INFLATION, LET'S MAKE SURE
THE WEALTHIEST CORPORATIONS PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
>> LOOK, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT -- WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS THIS PAST YEAR, ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THE WEALTHIEST
AMONG US ARE PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
>> BUT HOW DOES RAISING TAXES ON
CORPORATIONS LOWER THE COST OF
GAS, THE COST OF A USED CAR, THE
COST OF FOOD FOR EVERYDAY
AMERICANS?
>> SO, LOOK, I THINK WE
ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO HAVE DONE
VERY WELL, RIGHT, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO CARE ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE TO SUPPORT A FAIR TAX
CODE THAT DOESN'T CHANGE -- THAT
DOES NOT CHARGE MANUFACTURERS,
WORKERS, COPS, BUILDERS, A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
EARNINGS, THAT THE MOST
FORTUNATE PEOPLE IN OUR NATION,
AND NOT LET THAT STAND IN THE
WAY OF REDUCING ENERGY COSTS AND
FIGHTING THIS EXISTENTIAL
PROBLEM, IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
AS AN EXAMPLE.
>> Tucker: NOW, YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE THOUGHT IT WAS POSSIBLE TO
TAKE TALKING POINTS THAT STUPID,
THAT BARELY LITERATE, THAT
CHILDISH, AND MAKE THEM EVEN
DUMBER.
AND YET THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT SHE
DID.
ARE YOU STILL NOT CONVINCED THAT
JOE BIDEN KNOWS HOW TO HANDLE
INFLATION?
DID THAT RATTLE YOUR CONFIDENCE,
RATHER THAN BOLSTER IT?
THAT HONESTLY THERE IS NOTHING
WE CAN DO FOR YOU AT THIS POINT.
YOU ARE BEYOND REACH.
IN FACT, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
AND YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS
COMING, YOU ARE A RACIST.
THAT IS WHAT WE CALL PEOPLE WHO
CONTINUE TO ASK COMPLICATED LONG
QUESTIONS ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
ECONOMIC PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE RACISTS, AND GETTING
RID OF THEM IS AMERICA'S
GREATEST PROBLEM.
HERE IS MSNBC TO REMIND YOU.
>> MITCH O'CONNELL WILL NOT COME
CLOSE TO WIPING AWAY THE LEGACY
OF WHITE SUPREMACY TODAY BECAUSE
WHAT, BECAUSE THEY MAKE UP PART
OF THE REPUBLICAN COALITION,
WHAT IS THE EXPLANATION FOR WHY
NOT?
>> THIS IS ALWAYS WHAT THE RIGHT
DOSE TO APPEASE THE WHITE
SUPREMACIST MOVEMENT,
FREE SPEECH.
>> EXTREMISM AND WHITE
NATIONALISM, THE RHETORIC AND
TAMER VERSION, IS NOW PRETTY
MAINSTREAM IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
FROM MACOMB OVERNIGHT?
FREE SPEECH IS WHITE SUPREMACY.
IT IS WHITE SUPREMACY,
FREE SPEECH, TALKING OUT OF
TURN, READING YOUR OWN SCRIPT
RATHER THAN THE ONE THAT CHUCK
TODD PROVIDES YOU IS WHITE
SUPREMACY.
THAT MEANS IF YOU ARE UPSET
ABOUT FOOD SHORTAGES OR
BLACKOUTS, YOU ARE A RACIST.
RACIST, RACIST, RACIST.
THERE YOU ARE COMPLAINING AGAIN
ABOUT THE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN
YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING.
THAT IS ALWAYS THE FIRST SIGN OF
A RACIST.
OH, YOU DON'T LIKE CRIME COME
YOU DON'T LIKE INFLATION, YOU
ARE AGAINST PUBLIC URINATION IN
NEW YORK CITY, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE, YOU ARE A BIGOT, PAL, STOP
COMPLAINING, YOU AND YOUR
FREE SPEECH.
OF CBS, A JOURNALIST, TALENTED
AND HIGHLY AWARDED BROADCASTER,
SHE KNOWS EXACTLY HOW RACIST YOU
ARE.
YOU ARE SO RACIST THAT
GAYLE KING'S FAMILY MEMBERS
WON'T EVEN GO OUTSIDE ANYMORE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I AM SO AFRAID, I HAVE A
NEPHEW WHO LIVES IN THE MIDWEST,
20 SOMETHING BLACK MAN WHO WALKS
HIS DOG AND SAID I WAS NEVER
AFRAID TO WALK MY DOG, NOW I AM
IN THE MIDWEST JUST WALKING
AROUND, MINDING MY OWN
BUSINESS, THINKING THIS COULD
HAPPEN AT ANY TIME.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IT WHITE
SUPREMACIST WILL JUST COME OUT
AND KILL HIM WITH THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
WALK YOUR DOG IN THIS COUNTRY,
THAT IS HOW BAD IT IS.
RACISM AGAINST GAYLE KING'S
FAMILY MAY BE THE SINGLE BIGGEST
PROBLEM AMERICA FACES RIGHT NOW.
IN FACT, IT IS.
THE PROBLEM IS DEFINITELY NOT
THAT WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
ENERGY TO POWER CIVILIZATION,
THAT IS NOT A BIG DEAL AT ALL
AND THAT IS WHY YOU PROBABLY DID
NOT READ ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
INTERIOR DEPARTMENT JUST
ANNOUNCED IT IS CLOSING MILLIONS
OF ACRES TO DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
SORRY, GONE, CAN'T HAVE THE
ENERGY, THERE IT EXISTS, BUT YOU
CAN'T HAVE IT.
YOU KNOW WE CAN DO, THOUGH?
BY FROM VENEZUELA.
YES WE CAN GIVE A 20 MINUTES AGO
THEY TOLD YOU VENEZUELA WAS
A REGIME -- VENEZUELA CAN
SUPPLY, WE CAN'T, IT IS IMMORAL
BECAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE,
EXISTENTIAL, BUT VENEZUELA CAN.
AND THE UNITED STATES BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO ALLOW THE
UNITED STATES TO BUY VENEZUELAN
OIL DIRECTLY.
WHAT DOES THAT ADD UP TO?
DON'T THINK ABOUT THAT.
RACIST.
IT IS LIKE THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
WHITE THE, AND IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE IT, KARINE JEAN-PIERRE
IS HERE TO REMIND YOU.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS RUNNING A
RACIST CAMPAIGN.
THE GRAND WIZARD OF THE BIRTHER
MOVEMENT -- WHICH BIRTH ORISM IS
INHERENTLY RACIST.
>> THE RACIST AND BIGOT, WHICH
WE ALREADY KNEW.
SPEAK WITH IT WALKS LIKE A
RACIST, TALKS LIKE A RACIST,
ACTS LIKE A RACIST, IT IS A RAC.
>> WE SAW THESE AWFUL VOTER
SUPPRESSION LAWS, WHICH IS
REALLY RACISM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> WE HAVE A RACIST PRESIDENT IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WHO REALLY
PUSHES HIS RACISM LIKE A
PEACOCK, BECAUSE I WILL SAY
THIS, WE KNEW DONALD TRUMP WAS A
RACIST.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, JUST CHANGE
THE TOPIC FOR A QUICK SECOND
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S RACIST
TWEETS.
>> SYSTEMIC RACISM AND HOW THAT
HAS AFFECTED OUR COUNTRY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE MOST
OUTWARDLY RACIST PRESIDENT THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN GENERATIONS.
>> THIS COUNTRY NEEDS TO START
TALKING ABOUT UPROOTING
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
>> FOX NEWS WAS RACIST BEFORE
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ARE RACIST DURING THE
FOX NEWS WILL BE RACIST AFTER
THE CORONAVIRUS BEARD
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT,
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE?
WE NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT -- AND BY CONVERSATION WE
MEAN YOU SHUT UP, I TALKED, WE
NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW RACIST YOU ARE, WHICH
IS VERY RACIST.
SO IF YOU CAN'T KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON OR GO TO THE DENTIST OR IF
YOU ARE ONE OF THE VERY FEW
PEOPLE, MAYBE THREE IN THE
COUNTRY, WHO